i can't believe we got through this
whole interview and didn't mention
idiocracy which
is uh controversial for me now because
when it first came out i loved it so
much and i still do
but the fact that it's playing out is
real now
is very disturbing to me uh
this this uh how we fetishize and seem
to love
who can be the stupidest person and
isn't it funny that everything so stupid
um is uh worrisome to me but um
but there's so many great things in that
movie i think one of my favorite parts
is when you look out the window
in a lot of the scenes that take place
uh in in the cityscape you can see that
no one knows how to take care of
buildings anymore so they're held up
with rope
there's so many things like that that
just that
they're using ropes to keep skyscrapers
from falling down because they lack
engineering knowledge anymore right well
i can just remember
being on the movie with mike and saying
like well mike are you sure that we can
do this and you're like uh you don't
think it's funny i'd be like well i
think it's funny but i mean i'm totally
immature but i mean is this going to be
able to fly but yeah i do remember when
the in the last administration they did
hire somebody with a for a very
important
cabinet job that was actually from
carl's jr and i thought
okay now that is pretty incredible
that even i will agree that it is
exactly the world
yes yeah it's starting to uh and and and
just the reverence they have for uh
these you know i'm over-the-top
entertainers and it's just becoming the
reality of our political situation yeah
right i mean people would ask me about
it and not always say well i actually
think camacho would make a great
president yes i mean he cared about the
people you know
he was kind of empathetic yes you know
he wanted to take action yeah he's
looking pretty good right now
yeah mike mike judge is a pretty
incredible guy i mean he is yeah you
know speaking of people like martin
shorter
but
somebody like mike is one of those
people i think they're people like you
that you know
came from like a big family where humor
was part of it and then you know the
national lampoon would have been
encouraged and just part of your every
everyday life which humor and being
funny but then i also think they're
those people that where it gets kind of
beaten out of you not you know
physically but you get constantly told
like that's not funny and like yeah you
you shouldn't do that kind of thing
where i always get a kick out of those
kind of people and i'm sure you've run
across somewhere is mike one of those
mike judges that's how it goes where
it's almost kind of a quiet kind of
rebelliousness and determination to have
like
kept going with their kind of brand of
humor and uh
yeah i always kind of admire people like
that even i remember talking to errol
morris one time and
the great documentary filmmaker and he
was just saying that
either his mother or a teacher had said
to him now if you think that's funny
you're sick
um
well i think that's kind of what can
happen
to some
you know really funny people when i was
in fourth grade uh our fourth grade
teacher uh said
it's this woman who was really severe
and scared us all and she's she's tough
and she said anyone who talks to
themselves is crazy
they're crazy and insane and i was
horrified because i was sitting there
thinking all i do
is talk to myself and do voices and do
like and when i'm brushing my teeth in
the morning and i see my reflection in
the mirror i'm like hey you
what's the scope i'll tell you what's
happening and phones coming out looking
good you are looking good today and away
we go and i was always narrating my life
and she declared as an adult and i'm in
fourth grade right that that means i'm
you know you're insane and uh i did
think i was insane for a couple of years
there yeah and i do think that there are
like kids that hear something like that
and think okay well you know if i want
to you know make a living and you know
you know meet somebody and fall in love
and have a family that they're right i
i've got to stop doing this i've got to
stop talking to myself right um so i
mean i think that's that's always been
one of my favorite things about
you know people out here meeting people
you know kind of creative people or
funny people especially that where
they've kind of held on to that kind of
their humor through yeah you know being
told it's something that they need to uh
kind of let go
yeah it is just not growing
there's no reason to grow up yeah as
long as you're paying your taxes and
being a moderately responsible citizen
yeah there's really no reason to be an
adult